Okay. Wonderful.
Jeff Hyman, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks for having me.
Really really great to have you.
You know, you had such interesting
positions in the legal space,
but also in the HR space.
So I believe you started, you were the general counsel
and you started the HR
at Pebble Technology, which I love.
I backed both Kickstarters.
Incredible.
Thank you
And then ... senior director at Google,
advisor to several companies.
I think Boosted Boards
was one of them?
Yeah.
It's one of my dreams.
It's one of my life goals
to be able to ride
on the Boosted board,
but I'm terrified.
So, maybe you'll ease my concern.
And you're an adjunct professor
at Santa Clara University
teaching about the legal aspect
of startups.
Jeff, what does that mean?
What does that mean
the legal aspect of startups?
Well, in the course at the law school,
what we do is
I try to present to the students
what the arc of legal issues are
that startups face from formation
to raising capital
and dealing with VCs.
And then key issues about
contracts and hiring people
and employment law issues.
And then ultimately
working towards M&A
and going public.
And throughout it
the focus of the class is really about
educating the students a bit
on some of the key legal issues
at every one of those steps,
but it's really about how do you function
in a startup as a lawyer
and what's the most useful way
to be a partner to all of the other
business stakeholders in a company
in charting solutions to navigate
through all those legal issues.
So, take me through this lifecycle
from you're joining at Pebble
as very early employee, right?
I think 35th employee.
What does that mean
being a good partner
at an early stage startup?
And then take me through the journey
of the startup up until the IPO.
So, I think it's really that,
it's an important distinction between
being like a law firm lawyer
or even working at a
big company legal department
like I did it at Intel or Apple where,
when you're a huge company
you have so much at stake,
so much at risk
and a lot to protect and to worry about.
And what a lot of those
companies’ legal practices
are really about
is identifying and managing risk,
whereas in a startup
you have very little to protect
and it's really about you're trying
to do something new
and you're trying to create and build.
And so the orientation I think there is,
and this certainly was my attitude
when I got to Pebble,
you show up
and there is no legal department,
there's nothing.
And there's a business that's trying
to accomplish something.
And really, your job
as the general counsel or legal counsel
is understand what the business
is trying to do
and figure out how can you help
make that happen.
And along the way,
how do you help build the company
and make sure that the company
is making really smart choices
about how it's pursuing
those business opportunities
in a smart way.
How it's complying with the laws
that it needs to comply with
or at least making really informed choices
when it's not.
And sometimes that's part of
what startups have to do too.
But then also being really smart about,
particularly in a technology startup,
you have a great idea
and now you're executing to it.
How do you do that in a way
that's gonna be protectable
so that you have
a differentiated advantage
and you're able to protect
that differentiation
sometimes through intellectual property,
sometimes through how you set up contracts and
relationships with external parties, etc.
So, there's a lot.
Yeah. I mean, looking in the background,
so besides being a part
of these huge companies,
very successful companies,
you've taken a very active role
within those more Internet of things
devices like wearable technology,
like the Boosted boards.
So, I'm guessing there, the IP plays
a pretty strong part, right?
Because especially today
you create some new wearable device,
and all of a sudden
across the sea on the east,
you have companies doing
almost the same thing for much cheaper.
So, what are the different challenges there
that you've seen with these
different companies
that you've worked with?
Well, that's and that's really, I think,
especially in the hardware space,
that's really one of the big challenges.
You can have
If you looked at like a Pebble watch or,
I had the same thought when GoPro
came out with their camera,
when you tear those devices down,
they're just made up full of commodity
off the shelf parts
that anybody can tear it open and copy it.
And if they can offer it at a lower price
because they have cheaper labor,
whatever the case may be,
you're in big trouble.
So, if you wanna have something
that's gonna give you a sustained
differentiated advantage to compete,
you've got to bring something
that isn't so easy to knock off.
And what are those things?
Well, at Pebble, one of the things
that we had was we had software.
We had a distinct UI.
We had a set of software features.
We had a really impressive back-end
cloud based systems.
We had a technology community.
Yeah, I developed apps for my Pebble.
Yeah. So, those are the kinds of things
that if you're smart about how you do it,
those can start to create moats
that will defend your competitive advantage
so long as people like the product.
I mean ultimately all these things,
they all devolve down
to the basic question of:
Are you doing something
that consumers want?
That's the ultimate challenge,
but I think that you can be smart
about how you decide
whether you're gonna try
to protect things through patents
and there's criteria and strategies around
figuring out that.
There's also a lot of strategy around
when there are things that
are actually hard about
what makes your product work
or how you assemble your product,
and if you keep those things secret,
you can give yourself some advantage
as well. So how you maintain
your trade secrets is important.
So, there's lots of different strategies
and law plays a part of figuring out
how effective a moat can you build
around the business.
And then how does that play, though,
into your role as leading the HR
at a company like Pebble?
Because in my mind, legal and HR
don't necessarily go hand in hand.
So, it's really yeah,
it's really interesting.
When I joined the Pebble
the first day I showed up
there was a recruiter
and he asked me to go
into a conference room and he said,
"Hey, you know,
you're also in charge of HR.
There's some things
that you need to know about."
And so, it isn't actually that strange
because the intersection,
there's a lot of HR that's really about
not only complying with a whole host
of employment laws,
which are really important,
but a lot of those laws are there
when you think about it
to protect and promote the interests
of the team and the employees.
And when you think in a startup
about what's something
that's really important,
well, it's the team
and the culture of the company.
And so for me, I had
a really natural interest and passion
for doing the HR work.
I still love doing it.
And I was really,
I was thrilled to get to wear
both of those hats
because sometimes
when you're doing the legal work,
it can be a little isolating
from the team writ large,
and you're doing things
that are important but maybe
don't resonate with everybody.
When you work in HR,
you're doing stuff that affects
everybody all the time
and the feedback loop is instantaneous.
You hear from people all the time
which I enjoyed most of the time.
I love it. I love it. Okay.
And now I'm gonna be starting a startup,
hopefully sooner rather than later.
And how can I as a founder,
as an entrepreneur,
I know nothing about legal.
How can I even go and approach
doing things the right way
and understanding and really complying
with the right things,
but also thinking strategically
about protecting the stuff that I'm doing?
Do I bring somebody in-house?
Do I go outside to a different company?
Sort of what's the best practices
with your insight
over years in this industry?
Well, now what you're gonna do
is call me.
Okay. Okay, it's done.
That's it.
So that's, you know it's funny
'cause that's really what this
consulting business that I run now
is really, in a way,
it's sort of my solution to the problem
that you just raised is.
When you're starting out
and it's early days,
it doesn't make sense to hire
a full time lawyer
at a really early stage startup.
But there are so many things
that even in the early stages
that founders want to get right
and they need,
they're not intuitive.
Most founders are technical.
Sometimes they're sales or
marketing oriented people,
but there's no reason to assume
that you would have
this very specialized knowledge
and the wisdom of experience to know
what are some of the better solutions
than others.
So, you can read a lot on the web
and then I think a lot of founders do,
and some of it's good,
and some if it's not.
There's lots and lots of law firms
you can go to.
And law firms are great at,
if you go to a good one,
there's a lot of subject matter knowledge,
but there isn't always a lot
of practical wisdom
and sort of street smarts.
And so, ultimately,
I think what you want
as a founder is to say,
"Okay, don't just tell me what the law is,
but tell me practically
what's the smartest way
to get from where I am
to where you understand I wanna go."
And I think that's really what makes
for a great in-house lawyer
or even somebody like me
who's a part time GC
and head of HR for lots of startups.
Somebody who brings
that perspective up in reality
like you're always weighing
risk against benefit. Right.
And sometimes, it can be expensive
to comply with every single detail
or to try to tackle
all the problems at once.
And you have to prioritize.
So, having that practical experience
to know, like,
what do I really need to do right now?
What can wait?
What's a good enough solution
vs. the Cadillac?
And you don't always need the Cadillac.
That's really the kind
of practical experience that you need.
But even in, especially in legal,
you have to specialize
in a lot of these things,
and especially when you're talking
about intellectual property
It sounds like you almost have to be
somewhat of an expert on the technology
that this company is developing.
And you're going from smartwatches
to electric scooter boards
to Google, Intel, Apple.
How do you understand the technology?
And how much of a deep dive do you actually need
to have within each of these realms in order
to be giving really good advice?
Well, it's one of the things
that's really fun about working
in the Valley is if you're interested
in technology and in business,
which I am both of those,
as well as the law.
I've had a lot of people I've worked with
say that I'm a business person
who happens also to be a lawyer.
And I try to think of it that way, too.
So, over a number of years,
you work on a lot
of different kinds of things
and you learn from hopefully really smart
mentors and practitioners.
But then, yeah,
you do have to learn the technology
because it it can be relevant sometimes
And sometimes it's not.
I mean, to help address
employment law issues,
it's not necessary that you know much
about the business or the product
or the technology.
But certainly when you're thinking
about intellectual property matters
or even structuring partnerships
with outside companies,
particularly if it involves like
manufacturing or licensing technologies,
you do need to understand at some level.
You don't have to be an engineer,
but the more you understand,
I think it can help you a lot.
Definitely.
And so, looking over all these companies
and all these years in your industry,
what are some of the common pitfalls
that you see founders or entrepreneurs
make along the way
that could be avoided?
I'm looking at myself,
things that I wanna write down
that I wanna make sure
that I do things right as I go along
my own entrepreneurial journey.
Gosh. Every startup that I've worked with,
and I'm working with
four companies right now,
they all struggle with a lot
of people related issues.
A lot of employment law issues.
Interesting.
And I think they also struggle with
how to build and manage teams
and do some of the compensation strategy.
Like all of that people related stuff
is a challenge.
And that's partly because
none of it's intuitive at all.
Like there's nothing intuitive
about employment law.
It's detailed and in California
it's shocking and surprising
what the law actually requires sometimes.
It's very unclear to both sides, right?
Both the employer and the employee
It can be. It absolutely can be.
And there can be a tremendous
amount of problem
when the relationship goes south.
And that can happen, right.
So, getting a lot on this
people related issues is a challenge.
I think also, that when founders early on
start engaging with the outside world,
whether it's through contracts
or through collaboration,
talking about technology
developing technology with outsiders,
getting that right with both
in terms of the contracts
that the companies are signing
and the contracts that they're not signing
and putting in place is sort of another area
where I see a lot of opportunity
to benefit from working with someone
who can guide you through that.
I think there's, naturally there's a desire to,
you see a problem you wanna go solve it.
And there's a smart person or a company
that's got some technology
that's interesting.
Let's just dive in
and solve the technical problem.
But if you don't set that up right,
and especially sometimes
before the work begins,
you can really be creating
some difficult problems
that you're gonna have to dig out of
after the fact.
100%. Is it very common
in your industry to go broad
and being at four companies
at the same time?
Or do people at your caliber usually go
and do a deep dive into one company?
It's a mix, I think.
I mean, clearly what I'm doing
I think is not the conventional path.
I mean, I've done being a part
of big companies and smaller ones full time.
By the way, what's the difference in that?
So, being in huge companies like Google,
and then being in small companies
like Pebble. Give me a little bit
of a taste of how different it is
from your perspective.
Well, so, if you think about the time
that I was at Apple,
I was part of the hardware legal team.
And within the whole legal team,
there was the software legal team,
and there was Internet services
which at the time was iTunes,
and the bookstore and all of that.
And then there was the privacy team
and the litigation team
and the patent team.
And so, the whole point though,
is you start getting specialization
and a more narrow focus.
So, even while I was a senior person
and ultimately led
the hardware legal team at Apple,
I had nothing to do
with all the really interesting things
that Apple was doing
in software and services
and it's completely cool
ways of setting up the Apple stores
and how Apple was selling.
I had nothing to do with that.
Yeah.
So, that focus and specialization
and sort of staying in your lane
is sort of the hallmark of working
at a big legal department.
And I had done that kind of work
for a long time at Intel and Apple.
And I was desperate
to get out of that narrow lane
and have the breadth of all the issues.
And also, when you're
at an Intel or an Apple,
it's like a giant aircraft carrier.
And it will be just fine
whether you're there or not.
And it turns very slowly.
I wanted to go to an early stage company
where whether I showed up to work or not
and the work that I was doing
was actually gonna make an
important value impact to the company.
And so, that's really what led me
to go to Pebble and have my first
startup experience.
And I've worked with
many startups since then.
What I like about playing the role
I play now as a part time GC
and head of HR is you get an exposure
At any one time
you've got this group of companies
you're working with
So, there's really interesting variety,
different technologies.
All my companies are very very different
from each other in their focus.
And you get this breadth of
people and experiences
and you're constantly learning
and then you can take those lessons
and apply them across all the companies.
So instead of being,
all of my experiences
what it's like to work at Pebble,
I actually now have the experience
of having worked with, I think,
eight or nine different startups
over the past few years with a detour
to be a business executive
at Google in between.
And so, I just love it. It's fun
and the variety is there
and I just really enjoy it quite a bit.
I mean, you're almost like
a walking AI machine
because you have all this data in your head
about all these different companies
and I'm guessing some things are
starting to come up that you say,
"Yeah. Well, I've seen something similar
a few years ago at this company."
And that just transcends every experience
that somebody can get in university
or reading in a textbook
because you actually lived
through crises.
You've lived through successes.
And you've seen all the different
complexities of these problems.
I mean, you hear investors talk
about pattern recognition.
And it's the same thing.
And it's funny because one of the things
that you constantly hear about
in the Valley is sometimes founders
greatly discount the value of experience.
They build a team and they're like,
"Just give me somebody who is smart,
enthusiastic, and they can be great."
And sometimes that's right,
but that pattern recognition
and the wisdom of knowing
when this kind of problem has come up.
I've seen this movie 50 times before
and I know that if you go this way
or if you go that way,
so, the smart route is go this way.
Like you only get that from experience.
And so what's fun now is to be able
to operate with that experience
and be able to apply
that wisdom of experience.
And it's really beneficial for companies
and it's a thrill to kind of
be presented with a problem
and you're able to offer
this perspective to the founders.
Most of the time
they're really really appreciative of that.
And that's also the kind of thing
that even the law firm lawyers
I think struggle with because
they're much more doctrinal
and they're still in the business of
identifying risk 'cause no law firm
ever wants to be in a position where
something bad happens at a company.
And you go back to the law firm and say,
"You didn't tell me about this.
You didn't warn me about that."
So, they're really in the business
of warning and risk mitigation
whereas I'm more in the business of saying,
"How do I move the company forward
but also navigate around or
through some of these legal issues"
I love it. Okay.
So, Jeff, expect a call from me
hopefully in less than a few years
for my startup.
But before that, I need three words
that best describe you.
All right. I'm gonna go with optimistic.
All right.
Determined.
A lawyer saying optimistic. Interesting.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Determined.
And I think the third one
would be evolving.
I love it. I love it very much.
And Jeff, I'm really glad to be
learning all this from you.
And we're both involved with J-Ventures
and I just love how I get to be exposed
to all these incredible
people like yourself.
So, thank you for everything
that you're teaching me
and I look forward to continue
collaborating in the fund.
And I look forward to working
together in the future.
That'd be great. Thanks a lot.
This was a lot of fun.
Thank you. Take care.
Bye bye.